So the argument for
RAID 6 being an overkill is that
when in RAID 5 a disk fails, it takes
up to a couple of days to replace.
Sometimes you have a spare disk and
usually a data center will have that,
so it's going to take less than an hour.
And there is a very, very low
probability that another disk in
the array will fail in those three days.
If it fails after these three days,
it doesn't matter because by then we
are back to being protected
by the extra disk.
So the failure of the second
disk needs to happen in the time
when one of the disk is
in the failed state.
But that assumes that the disk
failures are independent.
But the failures can be
related to each other,
in which case this is
not correct to assume.
A typical scenario where
this can happen is,
let's say that we have a RAID five with
five disks and one of the disk fails.
Let's say that disk number
two in the array has failed.
The system reports that
a disk has failed and
continues functioning normally.
Remember than it can do that
with one failed disk in RAID 5.
And now the operator gets a replacement
disk, opens the computer case and
sees five drives like this,
knows that the number two has failed so
takes this one out and
puts the new drive in.
But for example, the numbering of
the disks was actually 0,1,2,3,4 so
we pulled out the wrong drive.
This was the failed one.
When we pulled the second one,
that was the second failure, and
now we really have two failed disks.
One failed because it failed,
the other one failed in the course of
trying to repair the first failure.
So that's, for example,
a case of correlated failures,
and in that case,
we cannot assume independence.
So pretty much when a disk fails,
the actions to repair it are creating
a lot more risk for the other disks and
may cause a second failure.
And that, for example, where you
want to have RAID 6, when one fails and
you're trying to repair it.
If another one fails for
any reason, independent or
dependent on the first failure,
you're still safe.